as voting comes to a close at this
polling station in Kano a plan to
Scuttle the election is set in motion
the police quickly stepped in to restore
order
at another polling Center an attempt to
disrupt voting was quickly brought under
control
for many voters this election for State
Governors and assemblies is more
important than that for the presidency
the level of government that is closest
to the people and it is also important
because
it's a presidential system of government
which a great deal of powers and rely on
the office of the executive
violence and intimidation have been
reported elsewhere in the country
but the use of electronic voting
machines led to less disruption than in
the elections in February the Electoral
commission says voting has been largely
successful in most of the 28 States in
Nigeria but many people's biggest
concern is about what will happen when
the results are announced in the next
few days especially after the disputed
presidential and parliamentary elections
lastly
security was stepped up for the vote the
strategy we have on the ground is enough
to checkmate
any on towards the development and any
person who feel he can test the ground
I'm advising him to change his mind
ahead of the vote technical glitches
during the presidential election in
February had raised concerns about the
ability of the Electoral umpire to
conduct a free and credible governorship
election
they have largely been addressed so
things are going smoothly
the supporting centers the voters stayed
away
but after several people were killed in
the elections three weeks ago and some
were concerned that that could happen
result for the governorship elections
are expected by Monday and many people
are waiting to see whether the streets
remain calm after they are announced
Idris Al Jazeera kanu Nigeria